we're just a week away from the start of
jury selection
in the murder trial of a minneapolis
police officer blamed for the death of
george floyd
the twin cities have been on edge since
that death and the tension is rising
once again
senior correspondent mike tobin shows us
tonight
the defense for former minneapolis
police officer derek chovin hinted they
will argue that drugs
killed george floyd in a brief filed
friday they cited the autopsy claiming
fentanyl was present at 11 nanograms per
milliliter
higher than chronic pain patients if mr
floyd had been found dead at home
and no other apparent causes this would
be acceptable to call an
overdose the brief was part of an appeal
brought by the prosecution asking to
reapply a third degree murder charge
ahead of the trial
this is our only chance today to
reinstate that third degree murder
charge we can't fix it
later on appeal derek chovin is facing
second-degree murder and manslaughter
charges
the third degree charge was dropped in
october
meantime barricades and razor wire
surround the hennepin county courthouse
where jury selection for the first trial
following george floyd's death
will start next week a security plan
called
operation safety net will involve
national guard and multiple police
agencies
plans to protect critical infrastructure
and police precincts
and secure fire crews if the city burns
again
council members are critical too many
city leaders
think that the most grown up response to
a problem is
always with force and always to begin by
sending people with guns
one plan was ditched in the face of
public blow back in the appearance of
propaganda
that was to pay social media influencers
to combat misinformation
and distribute messages from the city
this was never about trying to persuade
or change public opinion
about any particular message police
chief madaria arredondo says there is no
specific information about plans for
violence following the trial
this time around he says the city has
had time to prepare
brett back to you mike tobin in chicago
mike thanks